on va revenir sur l'affaire Palmade qui
connaît des rebondissements 8 mois après
le grave accident causé par l'humoriste
on a appris que quelques jours après
l'audition de Pier palmat j'ai juste
d'instruction son dealer présumé a été
arrêté on va recevoir le producteur
historique de pierre palmat qui était
déj venu nous voir un Claude fourni
Claude a repéré de nombreux talents il
sera avec nous pour nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé et les soirées qui auront
coûté la carrière de de de Pierre Michel
marie aussi sera là pour nous dire les
dernières infos sur cette affaire
d'abord regardez Muriel Robin qui s'est
confié sur pierre Palm dans l'émission
en appartti diffusé sur Canal plus
regardez vous avez eu le sentiment vous
de tenir ce rôle là aussi un peu d'ange
gardien comme Michel Bouquet à vos côté
auprès de Pierre Palmade oui oui oui
c'est très exact ange gardien oui parce
que l'ange n'attend pas de d'amour en
retour et il valait mieux ne pas en
attendre je m'étais
dit peut-être pour lui donner
ce quelque chose que j'aurais aimé qu'on
me
donne
tu pourras me faire tout ce que tu veux
je serai là je t'aimerais comme une mère
idéale absolu et aujourd'hui c'esthoire
ancienne
ou bonsoir
Michel merci Claude d'ê avec nous
bonsoir qui éta déjà venu nous voir un
producteur historique de Pierre palmad
et Michel on a appris donc que le dealer
de Pierre palmad aurait été interpellé
oui alors au lendemain de l'accident en
du 10
février palmad a été entendu par les
autorités judiciaires et en réalité il y
a eu trois enquêtes trois enquêtes l'une
portant sur
l'accident là c'est la sécurité publique
une portant les stup sur les stupes
parce que en réalité pierre palmat dans
ses
explications dit qu'il avait juste avant
l'accident
commandé auprès de son dealer
de la de la drogue et donc il avait
contacté son dealer qui lui avait amené
de la drogue et d'ailleurs on se demande
même si au moment de l'accident il
n'était
pas ça va aller cy Michel je vais vous
dire on a un gros problème parce que on
est il vous imite
tellement c'est un énorme souci autant
dire les choses je dis voilà autant dire
les Ch voilà moi c'est dit voilà ça va
mieux alors quand vous arrivez à chaque
fois c'est pour des drames en plus à
chaque fois c'est c'est compliqué donc
oui là c'est un semidrame enfin
l'accident c'est un drame mais
l'arrestation des dealer c'est beaucoup
moins alors donc en réalité dans ses
explications dans ses auditions Pierre
Palmade explique qu'il a un dealer à
titré enfin un il y en a plusieurs mais
ce jour-là juste avant l'accident il
avait commandé de la drogue il a demandé
à son dealer de lui livrer sa drogue à s
lit bon
et évidemment il donne un nom qui est un
n inventé c'est un pseudonyme winter
donc les gendarmes ont pour winter hiver
voilà hiver et on était en février très
bien voilà donc ça
colle rajez pas
Michel si tu te mets à déconner aussi
mich là on s'en sort plusz allezzz
alors donc les gendarmes trava très
compliqué à faire de téléphonie parce
que le téléphone de Pierre Palmade ça
c'est pas très compliqué on peut
remonter les appel mais bien évidemment
les dealers ils sont pas dans l'annuaire
ils ont pas pignon sur rue donc c'est
des téléphones balour comme on dit des
téléphones dédiés des téléphones qui
sont jamais à leur nom et donc la
gendarmerie est obligé de faire des
recoupements je pas rentrer dans le
détail parce que sinon on pour une heure
toujours estil déjà déjà là c'est c'est
long là c'est bon merci Jean-Marie allez
et donc et donc ils arrivent à remonter
au fil des mois euh une équipe de de
trafiquant de stup euh et ils ont
interpellé lundi euh quatre individus
euh entre 21 et 31 ans euh des
interpellations à nemour d'autres en
scène SaintDenis ces individus ont été
placés en garde à vue trois ont été
déférés mercredi devant le parquet de
Melin et ils se il dont alors il y a un
délai ils appellent ça
une une comparition à délai différés il
seront ils seront condamnés enfin ils
seront jugés pardon je vais un peu vite
en besogne ils seront jugés dans 2 mois
alors on a appris que Pierre Palmade
avait été entendu il y a quelques jours
par par la juge d'instruction mardi
dernier pour être exact s'est rendu au
tribunal judiciaire de Paris pour
répondre à un interrogatoire donc de
cette juge d'instruction les charges les
plus lourdes risquent risquent d'être
abandonné oui alors parce que on a les
fameuses expertises qui sont rentré et
l'expertise dit qu'en réalité l'enfant
qui était dans le ventre de sa de sa
mère et mort n'a pas vécu et à partir du
moment où il n'a pas vécu on peut pas
tuer que un enfant qui n'a pas vécu il
risque pas de prison à ton avis il
risque une peine de prison mais
symbolique et je ne pense pas que ça
soit de toute façon la solution oui ah
ou ouais c'est ça est-ce qu'il a eu un
traitement de faveur pour toi non non je
crois pas on avait déjà parlé moi je
pense qu' complement
défaveur parce que si sil c'était pas
appelé Palmade à mon avis il aurait eu
été beaucoup moins embêté que que ça
alors Claude fourn son producteur
historique est avec nous 2007 tu as
sorti un livre Claude qui s'appelle
ligne brisée dans lequelle tu racontes
son parcours et la difficulté de se
sortir des problèmes de drogue c'est
vous qui avez des c'est vous qui aviez
découvert per Palm vous étiez di nous
voir oui mais oui oui c'est c'est moi
qui l'ai découvert et et lui m'a fait
découvrir un autre grand monsieur de de
l qui est là Marie Jean-Marie on était
au pointvgule tous les deux et et Claude
nous a produit tous les deux Claude B
moi aussi il m'a produit Claude ah oui
c'est vrai claud il nous a perdu tous
les trois ouais ouis moi il m'a toujours
regardé moi
t'inquiète toujours mon Claude tu as été
marqué par l'affaire palmat par cette
Affa oui j'ai été marqué parce
que d'abord parce que j'ai beaucoup
entendu que ah il aura rien parce que il
est connu parce que c'est c'est c'est
dégueulasse ça serait or depuis je me
suis renseigné il y a énormément de cas
similaires de fait divers similaires je
crois 700 à peu près parant ouis emprise
conduite sous emprise
euh alcool c'était bon c'était son
premier délit en terme de voiture mais
sinon c'était pas son sa première
condamnation il y a des gens qui au bout
de plusieurs condamnations font plus
rapidement de la prison que lui quand
même alors je fini ce que j'avais
commencé non non c'est pas grave et
effectivement j'entendais beaucoup de
choses et ça me et quand on m'a proposé
de venir ici je suis venu juste dire que
je n'excuse rien simplement que le débat
c'était il doit aller en préventive oou
il doit se faire soigner moi je disais
il faut d'abord qu'il se fasse soigner
ouais parce que d'abord ça sert à rien
mettre un malade en prison il vaut mieux
que le gars soit au moins conscient à
son procès il sait j'en suis certain
Jean-Marie tu dois te savoir j'en suis
certain qu'il sait lui-même tous les qui
l'a créé et qui l' causé on a vu que le
dealer de Pierre palmad avait été arrêté
donc là euh il a toujours assumé tre
dangereux à cause de la drogue pierre
palmad il a toujours ass sué être
palman pas du tout je sais pas ce que tu
veux dire par là myiam non non il a il a
B il a été d'ailleurs assez frivole à
certain moment et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que lui reproche ses proches comme comme
mriel rein c'est que plusieurs fois ils
l'ont alerté en lui disant ça allait mal
se finir et que il a continué continué
continué à se droguer malgré malgré
toutes les tous les conseils de ses amis
alors Claude il Ta fait de nombreuses
soirées avec lui il se passait quoi dans
ces soirées parce que c'est impression
alors j'ai fait beaucoup de soirées avec
lui mais pas
forcément les soirées je je voulais
parler justement des des soirées ouais
il y a jeabord un cadre général souvent
il y a deux soirées dans une soirée
ouais il y a tu vas à un cocktail tu vas
un vernissage tu vas faire une émission
de télé et cetera et là il y a déjà une
possibilité de faire le con bien sûr et
puis après il y a les gens que tu aimes
bien que tu retrouves ailleurs jeis
qu'est- qu'il a non non allezy continuez
continuez Ren et ensuite tu peux
retrouver il a dit j'ai rien fait moi
mich ah mais j'ai rien fait alors il a
deux types de et donc la deuxème partie
souvent plus plus intime c'est tu te
retrouves entre amis de de différents
milieux et là tu c'est plus intime et
beaucoup plus comment dire sportif ouais
ça veut dire quoi sportif dis-moi la
vérité bah je vous laisse Imagineer on
fait du sport se non non c'est quoi on
fait du sport sexuel du sport ouais
sexuel il y a des chambres il y a du
sport non non mais je veux dire il se
passe des choses oui ouioui c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il veux dire là myiam pas
il par des k sex non ah non moi j'ai
jamais fait
ça mais à mon époque ça existait pas les
cam non mais c'était à quelle fréquence
ces soirées là oh ça peut arriver
plusieurs fois par semaine non çaz pas
les mecs mais le problème c'est que la
soirées est en de jours ah ouais d'c la
soirée cétait en 2 jours la soirée il y
a des soirées qui durent de jours
absolument et trois fois par semaine se
fait donc tous les jours la semaine
voilà
incroyable incroyable juste Claude euh
c'est c'est non mais c'est soiré il y
avait il y avait la de la drogue il y
avait de la drogue bien sûr j'arrive pas
de le dire non tu dis qu' faisait du
sport bah oui bah du sport dans je dire
qu'on s'amusait alors il y avait de
l'alcool oui c'est ça que tu veux savoir
il y avait de l'alcool pierre palmat
faisait venir enfin aurait je vais
utiliser le conditionnel faisait venir
aussi donc de la drogue mais aussi des
escorts Boys et c'est là que ça a
dégénéré moi je je j'ai j'ai fait
énormément de soirées avec lui mais
c'était plutôt on se retrouve au resto à
l'amazonial on allait chez nos amis Tony
et je sais plus et Bertrand et Bertrand
P son
à son âme oui et on allit au banane à
café et cetera là toute cette partie de
soirée on les faisait ensemble d'accord
et moi les quelques potes que que que je
connaissais ou euh dans ce caslà ceux
qui qui m'intéressai un peu plus que
d'autres je leur donné rendez-vous chez
moi ou chez eux et là c de après il y
avait l'after l'after qui démar à 11h du
matin le lendemain de la fête et qui
continue jusqu'à le aprèsdain jusquà la
soirée voil jusqu'à la soirée où là il
ça peut durer de 3 jours la soirée de 3
jours mais il y a pas besoin pas de
pinule je veux te dire de mon temps en
tout cas et à dire que moi il y a très
longtemps que c'est fini ça non mais tu
fais ce que
tu si j' conseille à vous donner ceux
qui ont jamais essayé n'essayez jamais
bien parce que le nombre de conneries ça
m'a fait
faire je peux vous dire que le sait
jeérouille non ouais c'est vrai j' opéré
fois dire c'est un pote vraiment un bon
très bon pote Claude c'était mon premier
j'été opéré qure fois en 2 ans et tous
les problèmes que j'ai respiratoire
cardiique urologique et cetera
urologique j'ai tous ces problèmes là
ils viennent d'après mes médecinner ils
viennent de ça et ça c'est les
conséquences et toutes les conneries
qu'on fait dans le métier parce que
quand tu es en forme et quelqu'un te
casse les bonbons tu lu envois pas un
courrier dire viens tu lui il fout dans
la gueule ce que tu as envie de lui dire
quoi tu es pas très diplomate oui al tu
regrettes d'avoir été je pense que je
regrette rien ouais comme il je regrette
rien mais si c'était à refaire je feraai
certainement pas le même chemin et je ne
vivrai pas cette deuxième partie tu vois
tu aurais mieux fait de rester avec moi
tu as vu ouais é tu vois on m'a interdit
de raconter une anecdote donc je la
raconterais pas quoi avec moi ah moi
j'ai pas fait de ah non non non att
stop stop il vont je vais me faire
engueuler mais non non tuas jamais pris
de dog sauf que tu t'es jamais rendu
compte que j'en prenais ouais c'est vrai
je t jour que c'est vrai bah oui parce
que moi on est parti 8 jours ensemble à
Lyon ouais je faisais mon spectacle
exactement après je dormais pas avec toi
au bouboui non mais on passait on
passait quelques heures tous les jours
ah oui mais oui ou enfin tu sais moi
j'avais commencé avant qu'on se voit
ouais moi je sais mais moi j'étais
j'étaisop lui il voyait rien du tout et
tout comme quoi faut faire gaffe parce
que la drogue fait faire aussi des
choses qui sont pas honnêtes pas sincèr
c'est on trah quand tu étais avec moi tu
tu tu t'en fout des PL de PIF oui oui
oui je sais ouis mais tu sa que je le
voyais pas du tout je te VO ça un peu
speed je te c pas non mais c'est vrai he
mais un bon message de prévention mais
tu te souviens quand on avait fait le
spectacle au Trévise ouais avec Stéphan
g et Jérôme Revon mes amis
ouiembrasse y a un moment j'ai disparu
du spectacle non pas j'étais plus co
producteur ouais j'étais complètement à
l'Ouest c'est ça il l'ont jamais dit bah
non tu sais moi je faisais mon truc non
mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai mon CLUD
tu sais que je t'aime et que c'est
vraiment un ami de longue date Claude
voilà et c'est vrai que Claude il
regrette il regrette tout ça tu CIS oui
puis surtout n'y allait pas tu as raison
moi je suis un repenti ouais et
aujourd'hui
si si on me le propose rien là tu
touches plus rienis un petit coup de
temps en temps d'accord
ouais un petit coup ça applaudit non
mais les
gars j al Jean-Michel
JeanMichel jeai jamais cach moi je suis
beaucoup sorti dans ma vie j'ai
fréquenté les soirées parisiennes et je
j'en ai beaucoup trop fait voilà à tous
les niveaux mais le le cercle là où ça
présente un cercle infernal c'est qu'on
fait la fête de la nuit ces produits
stupéfiants vous aide à faire la nuit
parce que ça vous excite ça vous donne
envie de de faire le con et cetera mais
ça vous empêche de dormir aussi même
quand vous arrêtez vous arrêtez la fête
à 5h du matin si vous avez consommé de
la drogue jusqu'à 5h du matin vous
n'arrivez pas à dormir même si vous
savez vous pouvez
dans malheureusement vous travaillez le
lendemain et pour être enfant le
lendemain tu prends prenez des
substances pour pour pas que ça se voit
dans votre entourage professionnel et
donc vous retapez mais si vous retapez
dans la journée ça vous donne envie de
continuer à taper et donc du coup vous
Contin tout je je m'en suis jamais caché
malheureusement je suis tombé dedans un
moment j'en suis sorti bien heureusement
mais c'est vrai qu'un moment mais dans
toutes les soiré parisienne ceux qui
disent qu'ils l'ont jamais vu ça ils
sont vous poser à tous les deux c'est
pas dangereux c'est pas dangereux pour
les les les les stars des stars comme ça
de de de de faire appel à des des
dealerss et cetera c'est une connerie ah
oui parce qu' après derrière est-ce
qu'il y a pas des problèmes ouais moi
j'ai jamais fait appel appel à dealer du
showbeze ouais il faut être con il y a
des dealers du showbiz genre oui des
dealers de des VIP quoi genre quoi ouais
jamais je suis toujours passé par des
connaissances dans le showbiz mais ça
peut êre ton attaché de presse ça peut
être un technicien sur un plateau tois
ah ouais ou pas ici
hein mais ça revient au même hein ou par
du local non mais ce revient pas au même
c'est quand le dealer il tombe avec un
carnet avec 20 ministres 30 députés des
chanteurs so y avait des ministres bien
sûr ça il y a eu des gens politiques
très connus ouais non dans les soirées
en train de faire des tu fas pas dire
les noms he non mais non mais il y a une
époque dans les années 80 o c'était une
substance qui était réservée un peu au
cétait Ann 80 eu même là dans les ouou
il y avait des hommes politiques oui des
députés en exercice des députés en
exercice en exercice qui faisaient des
exercices ou qui sont là en exercice et
je me souviens que dans une clinique où
j'ai été où je suis allé de mon propre
Pling je veux dire pour arrêter il y
avait des des députés qui venaient
dormir à la clinique le soir pour le
pour se contrôler pour pas faire le con
la nuit non ah ouais mais dans toute la
France il y a pas une soirée en France
où j'ai été invité et cetera où il y a
pas quelqu'un dans la soirée qui vous
propose quelque chose il y en a partout
c'est plus du tout une drogue un peu de
un peu obscure tabou des riches et
cetera même dans les soiré étudiantes en
a il y en a c'est tellement pas cher
maintenant on a vu on a vu tu crois que
tu trouves pierre palmat si si on est là
aujourd'hui qui un mec qui a un talent
exceptionnel c'est c'est ça qu'il a
foutu dedans faut le dire aux jeunes qui
nous regarde à tous les jeunes moin
le le problème c'est que moi je me suis
arrêté il y a une vingtaine d'années et
lui il a continué il se serait arrêté il
y a 20 ans ce serait le roi du monde
aujourd'hui je parle son talent il y a
un animateur moi très connu je peux pas
dire son nom qui m'a dit un jour il m'a
dit tu vois il y a des gens ils m'ont
dit noun il prend de la la coque j'ai
dit si noun a prené de la coque il
pourrait pas faire une quotidienne
pendant 12 ans c'est impossible il dit
mooi m'a dit moi j'ai pas pu j'ai pas pu
tenir en quotidienne il m'a dit c'est
impossible j'ai dévissé j'ai j'ai
dérouillé parce que j'ai voilà j'étais
j'étais voilà malheureus au bout d'un
moment ça tout casse he c'est ça y est
en fait tout casse non mais c'est vrai
tu regrettes aujourd'hui Claude
franchement oui oui tu as eu des gros
problèmes de santé à cause de ça c'est
je l' vu en ce moment
ouais je dois me ref opérer dans un mois
je opéré il y a un mois PERP là je te
jure ça me rend fou parce que je je
t'aime tellement mon claud tu es un mec
tu avais un talent exceptionnel de
producteur tu es tu et je vous dis je
suis pas mort encore je
sais non mais je sais système écro en
direct non non non non et honnêtement si
vous en prenez je le sauraai depuis
longtemps mais je l'aurais depuis bien
longtemps notamment quand on fait des
directs enfin des émissions et les
primes après et vous quittez jamais le
plateau vous restez toujours ici la pub
vous restez ici vous prenez une note
vous déconnez avec nous et cetera vous
enchaînez sur un prime parfois il y a 5
6h de tunnel d'émission comme ça en live
en direct comme ça quelqu'un qui en
prend je peux vous dire trois fois il
sort il va aux toilettes il en prend il
revient après jamais y a des animateurs
hein c'est qui encore un ping encore
uning d'ailleurs c'est la soirée euh oui
c'est moant que non il y a des des
animateurs très connus qui sont qui sont
plus là aujourd'hui je parle pas de la
rue forcément mais je parle de d'un mec
qui faisait des grandes émissions
hebbdomadaires familiales qui entre
sortait quatre fois l'après-midi du ou
CIN fois du du plateau ouais ouais pour
se revigorer
ouais c'est ouais c'est fou c'est alors
c'est le cadreur qui est te parl
ah que tu un connard
non non je rigole non non mais Claude
aujourd'hui sur l' sur l'affaire Pierre
Palmade est-ce que tu l'as eu au
téléphone est-ce que tu as essayé de l'
est-ce qu'il a essayé de te parler non
non non non non non non j'ai il y a eu
énormément de gens qui m'ont qui ont
trouvé ma position quand je suis venu je
sais plus c'était en avril mai ouais ça
ouais qu' trouvé que c'était c une
position mesurée honnête ouais bien sûr
ça me fait de la peine mais pour moi les
victimes c'est la famille est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres pierre palmad en en substance
voilà qui voilà d'autres humoristes ou
d'autres personnes qui sont en ce moment
tu as envie de leur dire vous êtes en
danger et vous allez tu vois des trucs
ou Mo bien sûr moi je fréquente plus
depuis que j'habite dans mon petit bled
à Cassis sousénard je l'ai casé madame
le Maire donc depuis que j'habite là-bas
à cass sous sén don je disais et bien et
et bien je je rencontre j'ai quelques
copines copains artistes qui viennent
mais c'est pas Tib qui m'amène de la
couque à la maison qu'est-ce si si tu tu
avais pierre pierre Palm au téléphone ou
si tu le voyais tu lui dirais quoi je
dirait faut assumer maintenant non mais
tu tu tu tu lui as dit un moment toi tu
as arrêté quand toi les conneries il y a
quand j'ai fait ce livre là que vous
trouverez plus mais Lig brisé déjà le
titre ouais euh il y a combien de temps
ça fait quoi 15 20 ans et tu l'as pas
dit à Pierre un moment fais gaffe moi
voilà j'ai arrêté on je voyais moins
déjà à cette époque là on se croisait
come et Jean-Marie on s'est
régulièrement croisé toujours ouais
potoau et tout comment ça va mais on
passait plus des des grands moments
ensemble Gill vous regrettez de pas lui
avoir dit faut arrêter à un moment vous
auriez dû être plus directif non j'
prenais avec lui à ce moment-là donc tu
vas pas dire au mec avec qui t'en prends
faut arrêter c'est pas bien et
vas-y mais là récemment vous auriez pu
enfin je veux dire avant que ça arrive
ces dernières années vous auriez pu
avoir on était plus en contact d'cord
mais il écoutait personne il écout pas
je crois qu' attention déjà moi
j'écoutais pas grand monde ouais oui
j'ai fait 20 ans de moins de de trajet
ouais mais je pense que 20 ans de plus
tu dois quand même les neurones qui sont
tu réagis plus comme tout le Mondeo
total je sais pas ce que tu en penses ça
m'arriie
oui ben le gros problème c'est que à
cette époque là comme comme l'a dit
Jean-Michel bon il y avait la fête
l'après la fête donc au lieu de de se
coucher comme n'importe quelle personne
un peu ivre à 5h du matin tu as eu ton
compte quand tu as de de la cocaïne à
midi tu es frais comme un gardon quoi
après avoir bu une bouteille de whisky
en plus du du clafouti donc c'est
effectivement un truc il y a un moment
où la plupart des gens disent ben faut
stopper parce que où demain je travaille
ou après-demain je travaille donc tu
fais stop le stop de l'époque c'était un
lexomil et tu fais de TR tu t'endor et
le lendemain est une autre journée
pierre n'a pas d'autrre journées pour
lui il en a qu'une à vivre et tout le
temps jusqu'à ce qui tombe par terre ou
qui déambule dans la rue sachant même
plus comment il s'appelle c'est-à-dire
son son problème c'est le stop Pierre
lui a dit tu disais tout à l'heure
personne lui a dit on lui a dit on lui a
rabâché marriel Robin et moi tous les
autres dit stop il faut là tu es au tu
es au deuxème jour et faut tu tu prends
un truc tu dors et puis après tu verras
si tu fais une autre fête un autre jour
non ça ne s'arrêtait jamais j'ai même
jamais compris comment physiquement il
pouvait tenir si tu veux au tout début
de ces affaires là ENF quand on se
connaissait donc il y a 30 ans on se
disait pierre palmat dans 2 ans il est
mort quoi ah ouais ça ça on disait déjà
je disais vraiment ça he disais c'est il
y a des trucs tu sais t'en servir puis
il y a d'autres tu tois il faut pas
oublier Jean-Marie que pendant cette
période là où c'était quand même bien
déjanté il faisait 200 dans l'année oui
oui bien sûr comment il faisait al pour
faire ExPEC ah bah il les faisait hein
ENF il y en a certains qui étaient un
peu plus long que d'autres sûr ouais il
y a des si qui duraient 8 minutes au
lieu de 4 ah ouais bon mais moi je l'
accompagné très souvent puis après c'est
Pascal Guillaume qui l'a accompagné
aussi ou c'est la phrase de de
Jean-Marie qui disait à l'époque on
disait dans 2 ans Pierre Palm il est
mort ça on le disait ou ouis exactement
on disait comment il pourrait tenir et
pourtant parce que tout le monde tout le
monde s'arrête au bout disons de 30 HE
quoi de ribouing mais lui il faisait des
paquets de 72 voilà et ça c'est pas
c'est ça peut pas tenir mais moi je
reconnais qu'à l'époque j'en prenais
avec lui donc tu nous l'as dit hein oui
mais je le dis donc tu peux pas dire à
un MRE de pas en prendre si toi tu en
prends quoi en tout cas moi j'avais pas
la force tu peux lu dire bah moi
j'arrête ouais c'est ça j'arrête verra
jeudi prochain merci en tout cas merci
Claude merci bonjour Marie
merci
c'est M